[Musik]
heute ist voll kam ein gast bei wünsch
dir was heute darf sich volkan ein
gericht wünschen nutzen kann ich später
bekam
du darfst dir heute was wünschen von mir
kochen backen irgendein rezept was
willst du essen egal was ich hab' ich
habe schon begangen muss oder oder sind
es im schnitt nur dann muss schmecken
was ist dein liebling bei dich ich kann
auch beides für krieg beide ist okay
okay
in zwei stunden sind sie fertig ist
wunderbar absolut okay ich schmeiß mich
in mein chor outfit und dann wird jetzt
gebacken
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein israel
ihr habt gehört volkan wünscht sich nuss
schnecken in vegan
ich habe natürlich schon viele viele
hefeteig rezepte auf meinem kanal
veröffentlicht deswegen habe ich gedacht
nutze ich dieses video als basic video
grundrezept für süßem hefeteig und zeigt
euch einmal die klassische variante mit
buttermilch und eigelb und die vegane
variante und dann machen wir daraus eben
muss schmecken ja ich sag ich jetzt
erstmal den ganz traditionellen hefeteig
außerdem könnt ihr alles mögliche
herstellen könnt buchteln machen ihr
könnt noch schnecken machen
zimtschnecken lostopf also wirklich
alles was ich ein feld es streiten sich
immer so ein bisschen die geister ob ein
ganzes ab nur eine top 2 eigelb oder 1
aber im prinzip ganz ehrlich ich gucke
dann oft auch immer was ich im vorrat
habe und wenn ich das eiweiß später noch
weiter verwehrte nämlich oft das eigelb
nur im teig ansonsten nämlich auch mein
ganzes kann dir machen wie ihr wollt
dafür nehme ich einen halben würfel hefe
zwei esslöffel warmes wasser 80 gramm
zucker 500 gramm mehl da könnt ihr
weizen und dinkel nehmen einen halben
teelöffel salz etwa 230 gramm milch 1
eigelb und 100 gramm weiche butter und
jetzt im prinzip erst mal die hefe mit
dem wasser verrühren
ihr kind auch einen ganzen würfel nehmen
aber der ganze würfel ist schon viel für
500 gramm hefe 11 500 gramm mehl
wie gesagt ein halber recht auch und die
prinzip verlängert sich einfach nur die
gehzeit die aufgezeigt
von daher ihr könnt auch hier noch die
jede menge reduzieren den teig noch
länger aufgehen lassen also hefeteig
eigentlich kann man da fast nichts
falsch machen
ich führe jetzt die hefe mit dem wasser
nehmen noch so zwei esslöffel zucker
dazu so ein bisschen als nahrung für die
hefe und ihr könnt jetzt gern einen
vorteig machen das heißt diesen diese
masse hier etwa 15 minuten abgedeckt
aufgehen lassen
dann fängt die hilfe auch schon an zu
arbeiten ihr könnt aber auch gleich den
hefeteig zubereitet dann geht aber ein
bisschen länger
ich mache oft schon gerne ein vorteil
der teig wird auch bis in feinste da
muss man sagen
und das gepäck bleibt länger frisch
daher werde ich das jetzt kurz abdecken
bzw kunst abdecken und bei
raumtemperatur gehen lassen oder einfach
im backofen bei der stufe mit
wasserdampf
das mache ich jetzt ganz kurz geht
nämlich schneller
[Musik]
schaut so sieht sie jetzt aus und man
sieht auch dass er richtig gut arbeitet
so ein vorteig hat eben nicht nur den
vorteil wie gesagt dass die geher zeit
später kürzer ist dass das gebäck
saftiger bleibt sondern eben auch dass
ihr schon wisst ok meine hilfe ist gut
sie funktioniert kann ja auch mal sein
dass ihr hefe habt ihr vielleicht ein
tag oder zwei tage oder länger
abgelaufen ist oder tv aus dem
tiefkühlfach und so könnt ihr einfach
immer sicherstellen dass sie wirklich
auch funktioniert und gut aufgeht und
jetzt im prinzip einfach nur darauf
achten dass die hefe nicht direkt mit
dem fett oder mit salz in verbindung
kommt das heißt ich gebe jetzt erst mal
das meer ein
den zucker dann die hefe mischung die
milch dazu sorgt natürlich auch für eine
schöne gelbe farbe im teig muss man auch
sagen also bei der veganen version nehme
ich dann auch gleich kurkuma da hätte
ich einfach dieses gelb mit drin hab
jetzt den teig mit der hand oder mit der
küchenmaschine kneten bei
küchenmaschinen immer darauf achten
stufe 2 maximum
ansonsten fängt die maschine an zu
wackeln egal welche maschine jetzt gebe
ich zum schluss noch das salz dazu und
die weiche butter um je nachdem was ich
mache verändere ich manchmal auch den
putter gehalt also bei buchteln nämlich
so ein bisschen mehr butter bei anderen
gebäck wie zum beispiel zimtschnecken
nämlich manchmal sogar weniger weil ich
ja noch butter einstreichen
und je nachdem welches mehl verwendet
kann es natürlich auch sein dass wir ein
bisschen mehr oder bisschen weniger mehl
braucht da schaue ich dann gleich wenn
der teig sozusagen bis hin zu weich ist
dann gebe ich noch mal mehr dazu und
oftmals mache ich den hefeteig aus
dinkelmehl 630 oder normalem weizenmehl
405 oder 550
ja und jetzt einfach für etwa zehn
minuten hätten
so sieht der eigens aus richtig schön es
ist sowieso so beim hefeteig wenn er
sich zu einem klumpen zusammen bildet
und dieser klub immer wieder geknetet
wird dann ist er fertig also wenn er
sich vom schüssel rand löst eben dachte
ich sogar selber kurz ich brauch noch
ein bisschen mehr aber ich habe keins
gebraucht also da ruhig geduldig sein
und wirklich erst mal fünf sechs sieben
minuten kneten lassen und dann bei
bedarf mehl zufügen
aber das soll jetzt auch nicht zu fest
sein und je länger hilfe geknetet wird
umso besser
guck mal da kommt schon von ganz alleine
aus der schlüssel raus ist nämlich die
reform den kurz zu einer kugel und beim
kneten immer darauf achten nicht mit den
fingerspitzen sondern eher mit dem
handballen kneten also so dann klebt
auch nicht und ihr habt einfach viel
mehr druck drauf und so form ich ihn in
kreisenden bewegungen zu einer kugel das
heißt die linke hand knetet den teig
oder falten in die mitte die rechte hand
macht es hier so dann geht es auch echt
super einfach und dann wirklich nur noch
umdrehen nach unten hin zur kugel formen
und fertig und ist so ein tag da ist
jetzt nicht zu weich aber auch nicht zu
fest je nachdem was ich machen möchte
brauche ich nämlich auch verschiedene
konsistenzen den möchte ich später
ausrollen und auch gut formen können
daher darf der jetzt nicht so weich sein
aber wenn ich zum beispiel eine focaccia
machen oder was anderes zum beispiel ein
blechkuchen da mache ich den schon gern
mal weicher und er lässt sich dann auch
neben also der davon ruhig richtig weich
sein
bei diesem butterkuchen zum beispiel
macht ihn so weit wie ihr wollt denn da
wird sowieso noch glatt gestrichen im
backblech und jetzt fertigte wir ein
bisschen also die schüssel haben auch
die oberfläche back trends prey oder ein
bisschen butter oder öl und jetzt den
teig entweder abgedeckt bei
raumtemperatur ruhen lassen bis er sich
verdoppelt hat oder wieder bei der stufe
im backofen
ich muss sagen wenn es schnell gehen
muss mache ich gern die der stufe wenn
ich aber zeit habt dann lasse ich ihn
einfach bei raumtemperatur und so werde
ich diesen hefeteig jetzt aufgehen
lassen und zeigen euch mal die zutaten
für die vegane variante
für den veganen hefeteig nämlich einen
halben würfel hefe zwei esslöffel warmes
wasser 80 gramm zucker 500 gramm mehl
einen halben teelöffel salz eine prise
kurkuma für die farbe 230 bis 250 gramm
pflanzen mild und 100 g weiche butter
und das ist auch eine vegane mutter und
der vegane hefeteig wird genauso
zubereitet das heißt zuerst werde ich
die hefe mit dem wasser und zucker
verrühren das ganze kurz aufgehen lassen
oder ihr macht den hefeteig gleich
weiter und dann verliere ich die
restlichen zutaten und achte einfach
wieder darauf dass das salz und die
vegane butter am ende dazu kommen teig
nummer eins ist jetzt fertig der
klassische hefeteig entsteht wunderbar
aus jetzt mache ich hier die nuss
füllung dafür verwende ich 200 gramm
haselnüsse 40 und sogar einen esslöffel
cacau einen teelöffel zimt ein eiweiß
und etwa 50 gramm milch das eiweiß ist
praktisch das was übrig geblieben ist
denn ich habe im teig in eigelb benutzt
daher ist es jetzt ganz gut statt
haselnüssen können wir natürlich auch
wandeln benutzen und wenn er das möchte
ich werde jetzt die haselnüsse kurz
verkleinern
ich hatte gar die so schon sprachfehler
okay wenn man mit nach hause zum wandel
muss weil geworden weil dadurch wirklich
so den schnitt von dieser welt wo statt
haselnuss schmecken kann man außerdem
mandl schnecken machen und start-stopp
ich dir was das noch später vegan
variante ist eine abwandlung das wäre
jetzt muss schmecken und die veganen
werden
mandl amaretto schnecken denn ich hab so
bitter mandelöl boah das wird lecker
sich gleich noch mal eine andere rezepte
idee jetzt hier ca
cacau ich hoffe dass er dadurch an etwas
luft genau das ist beim ostafrika katrin
ab
[Musik]
und die masse sollte jetzt eine schöne
streichfähige masse sein ich sehe schon
ich brauche ein bisschen mehr milch das
kann jetzt auch sein weil das eiweiß zum
beispiel etwas kleiner war
und wenn ihr das auch zubereitet ein
bisschen stehen lässt dann ist ja auch
noch ein bisschen nach also wenn es so
ist ist es fast perfekt ich brauche
jetzt echt nur noch ein schluck milch
damit rein
[Musik]
jetzt werden die skis geformt teppich zu
gras über meine wortwahl gemacht und da
nehme ich jetzt schon ein bisschen mehl
untendrunter jugend drauf der soll jetzt
auch nicht kleben also ganz bitter ein
bisschen aufpassen denn ich will später
wirklich perfekte noch schmecken jetzt
zu einem großen rechteck ausrollen
da kommen jetzt die füllung drauf und
wie gesagt wenn sie sich gut
verstreichen lässt das merkt man auch
schon beim umrühren dann ist sie perfekt
ansonsten einfach noch flüssigkeit dazu
geben
[Musik]
und was das ganze noch ein bisschen
krank haben möchte kann jetzt zum
beispiel noch gehackte nüsse drauf geben
habe ich ja auch immer da gehackt und
gerüstet die riechen halt echt extrem
gut und schmecken gut
[Musik]
und jetzt schön gleichmäßig auf rollen
vorher form ist gerne noch mal ehrlich
zu
und ihr könnt die nuss schnecken gerne
jetzt einfach schon runter schneiden
wenn er gewollt dass t40 perfekt werden
dann friert sie doch kurz ein und später
werde ich sie auch mit einem faden
schneiden und gar nicht mit einem messer
haben sie nicht zu zerdrücken und weil
die rolle so jetzt nicht auf mein paket
passt werde ich sie schon mal halbieren
ich sehe jetzt schaue ich musste doch
gar nicht einfrieren die werden so auch
richtig schön
daher ist sie direkt zu befahren werden
sie eben nicht zerdrückt wie wenn ihr
jetzt ein messer nehmen würdet und die
werden ja praktisch von außen so
zusammengequetscht
und deswegen behalten sie eben diese
schöne runde form schlägt jetzt direkt
auf dem backblech
wir können es jetzt so ungefähr 2 cm
dick zu schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier die zwei bleche
gefüllt natürlich habe ich am ende so
zwei jetzt nicht so perfekt und schön
aussehen aber das macht gar nichts
entweder lasst ihr jetzt die nuss
schmecken kurz überlegt was ich gesagt -
schnecken abgedeckt noch mal etwa eine
halbe stunde ruhen und backt sie dann im
heißen ofen dann könnte auch beide
welche gleichzeitig backen bei heißluft
oder ihr gebt sie jetzt in den kalten
ofen
da würde ich jetzt aber vorschlagen das
erste blech in kalten ofen dann den ofen
anschalten damit praktisch beim
aufwärmen des ofens der teig noch schön
mit aufgehen kann
das zweite blech kann dann so lange
abgedeckt holen und dann könnt ihr
praktischen fliegenden wechsel machen
das erste blech rausnehmen zweiter ist
dann ja schon aufgegangen und dann
backen so können da auch ein bisschen
zeit sparen muss ich sagen das heißt die
werden jetzt gebacken kommen den
backofen und ich zeige euch jetzt schon
mal was ich für die die veganen mandl
schnecken benutze
[Musik]
für die vegane version und die mandeln
muss schmecken wandel schnecken nämlich
im prinzip 200 gramm mandeln
ich habe hier bittermandel schmeckt
einfach super lecker nach amateur dem
zucker dass das kakaopulver habe ich
auch gleich gelassen
statt eiweiß nämlich jetzt einen
esslöffel leinsamen so ein bisschen für
die bindung und einfach pflanzliche mild
das war's zubereitung ist exakt gleich
die leinsamen bitte aufmalen
[Musik]
und jetzt hier auch alle zutaten
vermischen und wenn ihr hier auch ein
trans drin haben wollt sowie beiden muss
schmecken dann nehmt ihr einfach
gehackte mandeln die ihr auch gerne
rösten könnte
[Musik]
und jetzt einfach die restlichen zutaten
auch hier dazugeben und verrühren bis
eine schöne cremige masse entsteht
[Musik]
ich werd verrückt jetzt gibt es im
schnecken und es gibt ja einen
unterschied zwischen frei geschoben und
angeschobenen sind schnecken oder muss
schmecken habe ich gelernt vom
brotbacken nämlich das was wir bis
gerade eben gemacht haben sind
freigeschobene muss schmecken oder
zimtschnecken die backen einzeln und
jede einzelne schnecke für sich hat
einen geschlossenen rand eine
geschlossene kruste was ich jetzt mit
den sitten und brand aber machen welche
szenen und rot die backe ich in so einer
form gebacken dann zusammen und dann
sind sie am rand nicht knusprig sondern
überall nur oben und unten knusprig also
ich mach jetzt zum schmecken weil ich
auf meinem blog in meiner app zum
schmecken eingegeben habt und ich hab
keinen schon kein schönes bild gefunden
dann habe ich mir gedacht das gibt's
doch nicht so häufig schon zum schmecken
gemacht haben muss es doch schöne bilder
geben also habe ich noch einen dritten
hefeteig gemacht da würde ich noch
zusammen bands machen kann und damit sie
nicht gleich aussehen wie die nuss
schmecken wie die man ihn schmecken mag
ich sie hier drin irgendwas cinema und
deswegen wollte ich euch noch den
unterschied zwischen frei geschoben und
angeschoben erklären was ich gelernt
habe
in der sendung wer weiß denn sowas weil
ich die frage falsch beantwortet habe
[Musik]
ich finde optisch erkennt man nicht
welche schnecken vegan sind und welche
nicht weg ich habs jetzt damit das nicht
eigentlich schmecken sie mir auch mit
einer puderzucker sind unklar so sehr
gut aber ich finde die müssen jetzt mal
so bleiben sucht jetzt nach balkan
probieren diese mit hasen sind mit
mandeln die homberger die sind nicht
legal
okay aber sieht man nicht gerne
lichenroth aber fast gleichauf
okay okay meine aufbiete kleine
bittermann steht stimmt
ich bin sollte ich beide rennen richtig
lecker soft
als vergleich
und nichts hier viel zu wenig solche
aussagen sind weicher wirken
eins zu null für die vegane also echt
gut und ich finde so als im bittermandel
schmecken richtig gut auch deshalb -
schnecken sind sehr gut deswegen
probiert's einfach aus die zimtschnecken
habe ich noch im backofen heute war ich
zur hilfe schmecken eskalation hier in
sallys welt aber hat sich gelohnt
also falls ihr danach machen wollt
findet ihr das rezept in meiner app oder
auf meinem blog
viel spaß wünscht dir ruhig öfter mehr
rezepte und mache
[Musik]